guys we want to we want to give a quick
uh yeah just a quick
in memoriam you just want to give a
quick tribute to all our
fallen fallen men this weekend uh luke
why don't we
show the people what why don't we run it
will be good let's run it
um you know and just while we watch this
guys please remember be respectful
uh you know this went out i would say
yeah this is not really a laughing
matter
uh this is a tribute so just keep that
in mind okay
let it go
[Music]
oh
oh my god bro first of all hold on
hold on yo nate thank you for yeah oh
yeah
yeah just a little just a little all
over there writing on my [__] crush
it's like yeah it's my i'm a wet ass now
for the rest of the episode
bro first of all nate 10 out of 10.
you know what would have taken it to 11
out of 10.
uh is if nate did an extra one
of spencer jones buddy and if it was
like spencer jones boy
in his fur jacket you know question mark
to 2021 you know what i mean
his boy that whole scenario man
wait that's the guy that was beside him
right that got slammed into the wall
right by
saul let's get that was the worst part
of that video
let's talk about that in a second first
of all i completely forgot about that
flying knee this weekend holy [__]
[__]
uh shout out shout out derek lewis man
he um
uppercutted the [__] out of curtis
blade's dog
that has to be the recurring bit now
just immemorium every fight weekend
that'll be the new fight corner like all
right you know usually we'll talk about
it for 20 minutes instead we'll just do
a quick rip just
pair respects to the falling and then
we'll move on
don't have to explain [__] yo your face
on the [__] on the knee was
priceless
somebody got hit by a train bro i mean
that's basically what it is
oh it's hard to watch i mean man
man did i admit hold on forgetting the
dude's name
forget the dude's name hold on hold on
what's his name was his name what's his
name
we did not i should have told nate to
get the eddie weinland knockout oh my
god dude
so there was another one oh the eddie
weinland one is brutal he's like on his
feet just going
just kidding and those were all this
weekend
yeah people got murdered this weekend it
it happens that way sometimes with the
ufc like you go a few cards and then you
just get a card where
everybody dies
it's like fighting you shouldn't be
laughing at that you shouldn't but
you're like by the sixth fight you're
like okay i didn't i didn't need that
much violence
[Laughter]
i saw six people getting ties to it yeah
so the barstool one was brutal dude bro
so
i i don't know what happened prior but
i've watched it
way too many times but it seems like
they touched up that kid because he's
got the bloody nose
and the dude in the fur jacket he's like
looking in the mirror rubbing his chin
and then he keeps going look at
me look at me [__] i think he's i think
they like got into it and he's saying
like oh you didn't do [__]
like he's like i'm good you know what i
mean
the guy in the fur jacket said that yeah
i think that's what he was implying
because he kept looking at his chin in
the mirror and i think this the
sweet poetry in that scenario is he's
the one who ends up on the ground
getting [__] annihilated against the
[__] wall
oh dude he that last the last little
bit of him like the the first guy gets
that's spencer whatever his name is
basketball player yeah
the first guy spencer jones okay so
that's spencer jones
the first guy like licks his fingers and
then starts [__] him up
yeah and then like later on in the clip
his buddy
gets taken up like this and and slammed
against the wall and it looks like he
gets knocked out
i don't know if he got knocked out but
he's getting pieced up
um so yeah what was what was great about
the shorter dude this is my [__]
fight analysis
him grabbing the blood off his nose and
holding his hand out like that
that's genius oh is that what he did
yeah he he grabs the blood and he's
rubbing it and he puts it in his hand
why did i think he was doing some freak
[__] like he was like
like like this like i think i thought he
licked it
and wiping it together nice like the
dude was like what are you gonna do
put that in my mouth or something like
that and then you said
a little decoy yeah no that was that's
the that's the
that's the greatest so he you know he
pulls it and he holds that out with his
hand
and spencer takes the bait he's like
what is he doing with that
and then he slaps him it doesn't not
even a punch it's a slap
oh it is so now his head is moved this
way and then he comes over the top with
the [__]
you know like it's almost like a cross
like cross hook
wow and then he pushes him in the chest
gets him again and then his boy
tries to step in and this is the best
part is boy's about to step in and try
to like you know
save him from get from the ass whooping
and then bloody knows boy boots we'll
call him boots and his homie
that's when he ties him up and he's like
[__] you better calm down
some boots is going to work piecing up
spencer
you could tell spencer's bad when he's
like this and he's like
doing the flailing like no more
no more i mean the dude went full mma
on his ass like rear naked choke all of
us she's putting him in a [__] arm
bar
a leg bar i don't even know i don't know
the terms but he's putting them in
every single position it's like at a
certain point the dude was just flexing
that he was an mma guy
which you probably don't want to flex in
this scenario because
that'll get you sued right um
i mean maybe his lawyer might do that
but you know the self-defense bro
self he got attacked i wish we knew what
happened like at the beginning
yeah either ways uh spencer jones got
his ass what
yeah and uh
you know it was fine you know people
people got to take l sometimes it's just
unfortunate that
you know maybe if if his lawyers weren't
trying to do a pr run and call him like
a superb guy
and make it seem like he was a victim
you know
then the internet wouldn't care as much
right if he just took his l quietly
and let his parents pay for his eye
surgery and uh but his parents want to
sue these guys and make it all
well okay hold on hold on i don't know
if this guy is he a bad dude or
something
the spencer williams guy spencer jones i
mean adams or jones
i don't know that he's necessarily a bad
guy but it seems like he's being an
[__]
in the moment but you know right right
we don't know we don't really know what
happened
no and to get in a bar fight like that
where you're kind of
like it's it's fair to assume that the
dude
isn't an mma guy like granted spencer is
like a foot taller than him right so
he already thinks he probably has an
advantage so that's probably why he's
picking on him
yeah then the dude gets rocked but like
i don't think anyone deserves a beat
down like that dude
almost lose your [__] eye that's
scary [__] man
and if you're a trained fighter like
that you probably shouldn't be bar
fighting with
dudes that aren't trained i disagree i'm
saying that
in the 21st century you should not be
getting into bar fights because of that
reason
so many people train mma now i've said
it a million times you should not be
getting into that [__] unless
you're willing to consider that that's
my take yeah and i think
yeah on the same side of the coin i
think you should be training mma
in case you do get into a bar fight
exactly
that's i mean that's how i see it he's
pushing him in the bathroom
[__] you gonna do [__] you gonna do and
he's like
i'm sure what i'm gonna do nobody looked
at his boy beforehand because he was
like
you could tell they had like a little
mma activate like eye
contact they were like dude is this
going to go down and his friend's like
it's about to go down he's like
that was straight from a movie the way
he looked at his boy he's like we about
to do this right now
and his buddies like i think we have to
they were so close to doing this mma
activates wow it was so close to this
it was like you ready
exactly i'm [__] ready bro you ready
you got this homie i know you got this
[__] dude you're the best striker in the
[__] game the best one
let's go look let's go let's go let's go
they have no idea what's coming right
now
[Laughter]
his boy being in the mirror like look at
me
look at me [__] and then hard cut to
just
on the floor the fur jacket oh bro it's
a fur jacket
anyone if you're in i mean you can wear
a fur jacket right
you know if you're inside of a bar and
you've been
in a bar assuming it's pretty sweaty and
hot in there
then you just kind of deserve to be
punched at that point
because you kept it on yeah because then
it's more of like a oh you just you're a
douche
[Laughter]
you know you can wear one outside and
you'll be like yeah this fur
i'm kind of a pimp and you'd be like
that's pretty cool but then you're in a
sweaty bar
and he had the turtleneck on come on bro
he was doubled up he was serving
should have lost both eyes no that's
spencer jones
i think they're just me i think they're
just exaggerating i think
maybe one of those you know maybe that
maybe that first
maybe that first [__] uh hook
just like you know took him out right
here
he [__] up his orbital or something it
could happen
it was probably from when he got slammed
into the [__] ground
or that and you just never know that's
the worst part
you